michelangelo's david is one of the
world's most famous statues that's
spectacular before the pandemic
1.7 million tourists a year
would visit the academia gallery in
florence to see the renaissance
masterpiece
up close chris livesay shows us how a
team of scientists with 3-d
technology is taking advantage of the
museum's lockdown to study
david like never before
good morning for five centuries
michelangelo has left us awestruck for
his sculptural precision of the human
form
and try as they might artists have left
us countless copies like this one
albeit never with laser precision like
today
flash photography at a museum can get
you some dirty
looks but these cameras are different
this one is a laser scanner
combined with the laser tracker
inside florence's academia museum
professor grazia tucci and her team are
measuring all
14 feet of michelangelo's david from
head to toe
with tools normally used to design
high-tech jet engines
this time they're designing high-tech
replicas
we are producing a digital twin
first and this will be useful
for the scientists for the researchers
for the monitoring in the future
microscopic 3d data that can be studied
on your desktop
in unrivaled detail when you get up
close you can see
every little detail the hand of
michelangelo himself
something you normally have to do in
person but with a digital twin
you won't have to they're also making
a physical twin the next step is to feed
the data into a colossal
3d printer then glaze the synthetic copy
in marble powder
the final product will star at the italy
pavilion of the world fair in dubai this
october
says academia director cecilia holberg
now if this is perfection
how good can a copy really be even
the best copy is still a copy and that's
the reason why
millions of people come every year most
copies of course
are a dime a dozen some more profane
than
sacred he's the biblical hero after all
who slayed goliath
michelangelo took two years to carve his
david out of marble
finishing in 1504 and giving birth to
the most famous sculpture of the
renaissance
originally placed outside in the center
of florence as a symbol of strength
he was moved to the academia museum in
1873
where he's lived ever since and while
the statue that will emerge from the 3d
printer may not possess the soul of the
original
it just might help us see it more
clearly
and david's digital twin should be ready
by this spring and it could become
priceless should anything ever happen
to the original scientists warn that its
ankles are cracked and
if it ever got any sudden stress it
could topple completely
for cbs this morning chris livesay
florence wow
technology's amazing i know right i love
that chris says they're the soul
of michelangelo and david because it
really is a soulful when you are up
close and seeing it
for the first time it takes your breath
away it does yeah
you seen it you know i haven't seen it
all right how are you doing
when's your birthday coming up when's
your birthday in august when's your
birthday coming up girl's trip
let's do that this year you know what
vlad